Thanks a lot.
You know,
that was pretty cool.
But I'd actually
like to see something
that uses
Google Web Toolkit a bit more
and App Engine more
to sort of test the limits
and shows exactly how easy
Google Web Toolkit makes it
to build very rich,
powerful web applications.
So to do that,
I'd like to invite up
Iein from Appirio
who's been working
on some applications
using Google Web Toolkit
and App Engine.
He'll show them
to you now.
Thanks, Kevin.
So I'm Iein Valdez,
a product manager
and developer
with Appirio.
If you haven't heard of us,
we helped some of the
largest companies in the world
do more with on-demand
and take advantage
of the cloud companies
like Genentec,
Qualcomm, and Starbucks.
So I'm here tonight
to tell you about
my experience building
a real customer application
using Google Web Toolkit
and Java App Engine
and sort of
bringing together
everything
we've seen tonight.
Now, in this particular case,
I needed to build an app
to help a customer
better manage
their recruiting process
and get the word out
about new job openings.
Now, as a developer,
I know Java but
I'm not an Ajax wizard,
and it was important to me
to spend my time
writing my code
and not worrying about
how I was
going to deploy it,
what stack
I was going to use,
or the tools that
I was going to choose.
So let me show you
what we built
end-to-end in Java
in just over a week.
So here's
our recruiting app.
And what you can see here
is that we were able to use
off-the-shelf GWT components
to quickly put together
an effective interactive UI
and also to style it.
And this is the interface
that a hiring manager would see
when they log in to the app.
We even have some nice
visualizations of our data here.
So let's go in
and let's take a look
at our applicant list here.
So I'm going to go ahead
and click into "Applicant List"
and you probably noticed
how quickly that loaded.
And the page itself
actually never refreshed,
and that's thanks to GWT
handling the Ajax calls
to App Engine on the back end,
pulling my data,
bringing it back up to my UI,
and refreshing it.
So that makes
for an effective
and really interactive
user experience.
So let's go ahead
and choose a person here
and let's go ahead
and edit their details.
And let's say
I want to change their status
from "New" to "Interview."
So I'm going to go ahead
and click "Save"
and you'll see
that we were alerted
that our changes have been
stored to the back end
and also that our data UI
was refreshed
with the new information.
So great--
we have a great, effective way
to manage our job postings,
manage open positions,
and now how do
we get the word out
about these job openings?
So the first place
I'll start
is obviously on
a company's public website.
So in this
particular example,
what we did was we took
the customer's website
and embedded
within the iframe
our App Engine app.
So we're able to use
GWT and App Engine
to power this UI
which used to be
hand-coded HTML.
We have all of our
job openings listed here.
We can get more detail
about a job,
apply on the spot,
or we can even
send it to a friend.
And let's say
I have someone here
that might be interested.
Oops.
Sorry about that.
Let's go back.
"Email to a Friend."
Going to send that.
And you'll see that,
again,
our Ajax notifications
and UI
was all preserved
within the customer's website,
which is very cool.
So great--
we can now get the word out
on our public
company website,
but, you know,
what's a better way
to get the word out
about these job openings?
So what we've done
is we've connected
our App Engine app--
thanks to Open Web APIs
and the cloud--
and as soon as this loads,
you'll see
that what we've done
is we've connected
our job postings
with Appirio's Facebook
Viral Recruiting app
which connects this particular
company's employees' friends
with open job postings,
which is a great way
to get the word out.
So to close up,
there are three points
that I think we wanted
to bring to the tables.
One, we love
the development experience.
It was integrated--
end-to-end Java,
GWT on the front end,
App Engine
on the back end,
there was no
hand-coded HTML,
it was cross-browser
compatible,
and we could debug
everything in Eclipse--
end-to-end, all the way,
from data store
up to browser.
Two, the app is completely
in the cloud
without servers.
So with no up-front
infrastructure costs,
we were able
to get our app out there.
And third, we now believe
that real enterprise apps
can be built
on App Engine.
In a little time,
using Standard Java,
we were able to build
a customer app
and get it out there.
So I appreciate the time.
Thanks very much.
[applause]
Back to you, Kevin.